Who would have thought that a toilet
could have inspired such an emotional
scene? You might need to keep a roll
handy to wipe … away those tears.
The regeneration episodes of "Doctor Who" always
provide a harrowing goodbye worth having a good
weep over. But none have touched the nerve
of a fanbase quite like the Tenth Doctor's
farewell with Rose Tyler. Often considered one
of the best "Doctor Who" companions of all time,
Rose's time-travel journey came to an end
in the second series of the "Doctor Who"
relaunch. In the 2006 episode "Doomsday,"
the Doctor and Rose are seen hanging on for
dear life after the Cybermen break
through a fracture in the universe.
Following a prolonged fight against
the scary metal men, plus the Daleks,
Rose falls through the fracture and is separated
from the Doctor forever. Cue the tissues.
It's not until their final moments together that
the true heartbreak reveals itself. The Doctor
manages to send an image of himself to visit
Rose on a beach, in true romantic style. The pair
exchange teary goodbyes, with the Doctor vanishing
before sharing his parting words. SFX Magazine
voted this scene as the greatest sci-fi moment of
all time back in 2014, with fans deeply moved by
the duo's painful goodbyes. Addressing the episode
10 years later, director Graeme Harper said,
"Just as he starts to fade away from
this dimension never quite able to
get the words 'I love you!'
out, he disappears completely,
leaving a devastated Rose — and
breaking all our hearts on her behalf."
"Rose Tyler…"
Dedicated fans might have a difficult
time dealing with any character's death,
but when their demise comes completely out
of the blue, the fallout can be unbearable.
Such was the case for the Season 3 death
of Lexa in The CW sci-fi series "The 100."
After being hit by a stray bullet,
Lexa loses too much blood and dies
shortly after. As Clarke happens to be The CW's
first official openly bisexual main character,
the decision to kill off the first woman
audiences see her have a relationship with
was immediately questioned by viewers. As noted
by Culturess, LGBTQIA+ characters tend to bear
the brunt of unnecessary on-screen death, and
many fans felt Lexa was just another victim.
In fact, the fan reaction became so
volatile that "The 100" bosses had
to officially apologize. As reported by E! Online,
executive producer Jason Rothenberg second-guessed
his decision in an open letter to fans, sharing,
"Their relationship held greater
importance than even I realized.
And that very important representation
was taken away by one stray bullet."
It's a scathing mark on an
otherwise successful show.
It might have reignited the
world's love for Kate Bush,
but Max and Vecna's standoff was enough to
make any "Stranger Things" fan hold their
breath. After the suspense of Max escaping
Vecna's clutches at the end of "Volume One"
of Season 4, the final episode proved to
be another punch to the gut for viewers.
"I thought we lost you."
"I'm still here. I'm still here."
Choosing to offer herself up as bait to distract
Vecna long enough for his physical body to be
killed, Max's second pass at levitation ends
in snapping limbs and blood streaming from
her eyes. This is haunting enough without the
added shock of watching a fan favorite fall
at the final hurdle. The episode offers
lots of emotion, but very few answers.
Even though the second part of Season 4 has
since wrapped up, fans are still mulling the
scene over in great detail, including Eleven
using her powers to revive Max. Some viewers
have stated that Sadie Sink herself deserved
better, while several fan theories speculate
on what the Duffer Brothers might have in
store next. What's more, Redditors believe
that this could only be the start of Max's
problems, fueling rumors about Season 5.
It's an age-old tale — a vampire falls for
a sweet vampire slayer, and the vampire
slayer has to kill the vampire in an unsettling
surprise. In "Buffy the Vampire Slayer" Season 2,
Angel reverts back into his evil persona
of Angelus. One thing leads to another,
and his soul is restored, which turns him back
into the benevolent Angel ... just in time for
Buffy to have to kill him in order to close a hell
dimension and save the world. Throughout the show,
Buffy has to make a lot of noble sacrifices
for the greater good. It's kind of her thing.
Their final farewell -- for the time being --
is just as heartbreaking as you would expect,
with some fans still considering the scene
as one of the show's most emotional. In the
seconds prior to Angel's death, Buffy tells
him to close his eyes before pushing him
into hell. She is then left in tears while
trying to process what she has had to do.
In the finale of Marvel's TV sensation
"WandaVision," the tables turn for a
superhero people may have started to feel contempt
for. Throughout the show's standalone season,
Wanda uses her Scarlet Witch powers to take
an entire town hostage to create the normal
life she has always dreamed of, turning from
a celebrated Avenger to a selfish villain. She
has been through quite a few traumas by this
point in her story: the death of her parents,
her brother, and her android boyfriend
on separate occasions. But even Agatha
Harkness pales in comparison when it comes
to conniving plans that hurt many people.
Wanda realizes how far over the edge she's
gone in Episode 8, "Previously On," which
includes a flashback of Vision delivering
his now-famous "Love Persevering" speech.
"But what is grief? If not love persevering."
This is the episode when Wanda begins to
see how dangerous she really can be. Fans
quickly took to social media to express their
heartbreak and emotion after the episode aired,
with Wanda's realization connecting with the lies
told by SWORD head honcho Tyler Hayward. It's a
lot to take in for any dedicated fan, but the
sadness might just be worth the payoff. Viewers
commented that Wanda could now perhaps be seen
as one of the strongest Avengers in the MCU,
giving her an emotional turning
point that's both flawed and human.
Preventing the end of the world is no light
feat, and sometimes ultimate sacrifices become
necessary. In "The Umbrella Academy" Season 2's
"743," ghostly Ben leaves the comfort of his
spiritual world behind by using the last of his
energy to have a heart-to-heart with Victor. The
pair have one last emotional farewell before
Ben disappears into glimmering blue lights.
While each of the siblings put forth
their best efforts to push ahead,
it's left up to the only non-living
human of the bunch to save the day.
His absence from "The Umbrella Academy"
had a noticeable impact on the group,
with fans acknowledging that it might
have simply been his time to move on.
You might be surprised to see Rick, and not
Morty, appear on this list. Sure, Morty has his
fair share of tear-jerking moments; living out an
entire relationship, as well as a harrowing plane
crash, before watching it erased by an accidental
timeline reset was soul-crushing for him, though
many fans laughed and saw the humorous side. Yet
it's Rick that delivers a gut punch when he finds
out his stranger-turned-nemesis
Tony the toilet guy has died.
In the episode "The Old Man and
the Seat," we see Rick's idea of
a private toilet heaven interrupted by
an outsider. Intent on making him pay,
Rick goes above and beyond to take his revenge,
only for Tony to show him nothing but kindness.
Seeing such a sweet and polite character last
for mere minutes on screen feels like a difficult
watch in itself, but it's Rick's sudden emotional
compass that really clinches this as an upsetting
moment for fans. As one Redditor explained, Rick
has always wanted connections that mean something,
but he also sees this as a weak part
of his personality. In true Rick style,
the friendship that never was still
makes him more bitter than compassionate.
In a relatively unexpected move, the sensibility
of "Casablanca" crossed over into the hit series
"Star Trek: The Next Generation." This specific
episode's existence is somewhat upsetting to fans,
as it maintains a meager average score of
6.5 on IMDb. Even while the contents of
"We'll Always Have Paris" failed to impress,
its final moment pulls at the heartstrings.
Fans learn that Picard and his ex Jenice
were originally supposed to meet at the
Parisian Café des Artistes in 2342,
but Picard never showed. Consumed
with life on the ship rather than his
romantic relationship with Jenice,
Picard opts to part ways and the
two fail to track each other down.
The emotional kicker comes when Picard
and Jenice finally get to have their
reunion. The pair's chance to
say goodbye feels bittersweet,
as some fans suggest Picard isn't made out
to be a great guy after all. Redditors do
agree that putting this relationship to bed
is charming and that it takes an emotional
look at what happens when things don't
work out the way you hoped they would.
"You're wonderful."
As far as "Supernatural" goes, "Swan Song" is
an episode that sets fans' emotional pulses
racing. In the finale of "Supernatural" Season
5, Sam is assumed to have returned from hell to
see something he never wanted to — a domesticated
Dean. The buildup to Sam's realization is deadly,
with Lucifer already claiming the lives of Castiel
and Bobby. While Sam offers his body as a vessel,
Dean finds himself returning to Lisa.
The heartbreaking final scene shows Sam
standing outside Lisa's home, watching the happy
family have dinner as if nothing had happened.
Emotions were already high before the final
scene aired, with Redditors commenting on
the rollercoaster of feelings between Sam and
Dean in the fight to win back control. Yet the
final moments cause a different kind of upset,
almost acting as a letdown to what came before.
Even while Dean assumed he was fulfilling
Sam's wishes of granting him a normal life,
the Winchester boys getting domesticated
goes completely against their hunting
nature. Regardless, some agree that
it provides a perfectly teary ending.
When it came to its Season 3 ending, the producers
of "Misfits" decided to go out with a bang. One of
the many catastrophic fallouts in the episode is
the death of Alisha in an instance of terrible
timing. Alisha happens to walk in on an undead
Rachel during a revenge-oriented knife attack
on the Misfits. Rachel slashes Alisha's
throat and she bleeds out in Simon's arms.
Back when it first aired in 2011,
Alisha's death made viewers sob into
their sofa cushions. There has been
plenty of fan debate over which death
in "Misfits" was truly the saddest,
and Alisha's often comes out on top.
According to one Redditor, her death is
so sad because of its layers. Future Simon
likely knows what would end up happening
to her, and that means their relationship
is stuck in an infinite loop. The rest of
the gang's reaction is difficult to watch,
with each of them functionally powerless and
unable to fix the situation. Regardless of
popular opinion, Alisha's murder
is inarguably cold and callous,
and could have easily been prevented if she
was in the right place at the right time.
"Star Trek: Voyager" loses a valuable member of
its crew in Episode 23 of Season 7. After finding
a colony of Talaxians that he wishes to help,
Neelix develops feelings for Dexa and her son
Brax. This leaves him feeling conflicted after he
finishes his mission. While his reason for leaving
is very much understandable, his departure is full
of emotion. With his fellow crew members lining
the ship's hallways to see him off, Neelix leaves
Voyager with a trembling lip and a sense of hope
for his newfound romance. Having never been an
official Starfleet officer himself, viewers were
left unsure what kind of farewell Neelix would
get, and the answer was positively emotional.
Some fans have since commended the episode while
others questioned why he had to choose
between romance and Voyager in the first
place. Executive producer Kenneth
Biller told Cinescape at the time,
"We often said, 'What would happen if Neelix
ran into Talaxians and had to make a decision?'
I said very early on in the season, the only
way I would do that story was if Neelix left."